There's a component in being a human being,...
...an essential part of being a human being that's about being expressive,...
...having fun and being able to move,...
...and physical literacy kind of instills these fundamental components.
Physical literacy is just like anything else, so numerical literacy,...
...alphabetical literacy, so learning to do math, learning to speak...
...it's just literacy in general, but physical literacy.
It's breaking down big movements into fundamental movement skills.
So, just like when you're learning how to read or write you learn the ABCs...
...and when you're playing sports, whether those be traditional...
...or nontraditional, you learn fundamental movement skills...
...like skipping, jumping, hopping, running, things like that.
It's about being able to reach for that top shelf,...
...it's about being able to walk up and down the stairs.
It's not just for specific people, specific genders, specific areas.
Physical literacy has a place for everyone and can help you in any way, shape, or form.
It doesn't matter whether you consider yourself an athlete or not.
It's going to make a difference in your life one way or another.